哈囉大家好 歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿放心理師
今天我們邀請的
大來賓是小冬瓜
哈囉大家好 我是
單程旅行社的小冬瓜
嗨 我其實是
知道你已經很久了
欸真的嗎
對對對 我記得在你出第一
本書的時候就很紅啊
欸 哪敢跟老師比啊
欸 沒沒沒 你出
第一本書就很紅
然後 談到就是因為讓很多人
開始去談到就是關於死亡
然後離別這樣子的議題
然後後來呢 就是
我們上一次遇到
就是因為原本就
答應說要來上節目
就我們就在 Ted 遇到
對對對
我在那邊遇到你
我也是有點嚇一跳
喔真的嗎 為什麼
就是 呃 也不是說你不會出現
在那個場合
因為其實那個場合
其實是交換禮物
他那個次的主題
但是我那時候一直
想說 喔 所以其實
就是這樣交換禮物這些就是
關於安寧等等
這些都是你很有興趣的主題
沒錯沒錯
因為在從事殯葬工作
以前年輕的時候大概只瞭解
說 喔 殯葬禮俗啊
什麼人過世之後
我們洗澡 化妝 穿衣 入殮
等等這些意思
那就蠻熟悉的
那是到後來自己因為家人
過世 成為家屬
才理解到說 原來
在面對死亡的課題
不是只有禮俗這麼簡單
你還有包含在臨終的時候
最後那一段路 如何讓自己
可以善終好走
不要有太多的 不必要的疼痛
然後還有很多的這種不管是
對於死亡的這種
未知的恐懼
或者是他人這一生當中
很多情感上面的一些遺憾
創傷 然後在生命的終點
他會有很多放不下的
那我覺得這些在
面對這些離別的旅客
我覺得他們都是我的老師
就開始去學習到說 哇 原來
死亡這個面體
其實還有很多 值得
我們去探索跟學習
更重要的是如果你
能夠越早去理解死亡
在你生命當中的意義
那你就會活得更有力量
因為你就知道說
原來人真的會死
那人這一生如此的短暫
那我應該如何
好好把握我這一生
活出我自己想活的樣子
但最有趣的事情是很多人
也不知道自己這一生
想活成什麼樣子
對 那我所以就開啟了一個
我覺得很有趣的命題
然後回過來做自己的殯葬行業
我們就有個名字叫單程旅行社
就是我希望
我們能夠翻轉大家
對於死亡的恐懼
就是我們不要那麼
忌諱 去聊這件事情
然後也不要狹隘只是覺得說
死亡只是在聊生後事
沒有 我覺得就是
死亡其實在聊的是你
生命當中的每一天
你要如何好好活
概念上大概是這樣
例如說那時候在
看你的第一本書
然後再聽你講
因為我自己以前沒有經歷過
就是殯葬行業
我覺得做這一行本身
有很多很多的挑戰
然後在我自己就是經歷到
例如說後來我爸爸過世
然後我自己必須獨立去面對
所有的就是
所有的
儀式啊
然後那個時候遇到了一個
我非常感謝就是一個非常好的
一個殯葬業者
對 理事
他幫我處理很多
也讓我就是在那一個過程中
沒有那麼的困難
然後我才發現原來
那時候從來沒想過這件事
結果後來才真正的感受到
關於就是最後的那一段旅程
這是一個專業
但是要走這一行
就是其實是很不容易
所以你是為什麼會走這一行
我自己會做這行業
我覺得分兩個階段
第一個是它是我父親所留下來
就是他在我23歲那一年
就是突然過世了
那所以算是臨危受命
就接了這個家業這樣子
那小時候的夢想
其實是想要當藝術家
所以以前比如說讀復興美工
都是那種畫畫 攝影
然後就奔著說
這輩子要成為一個創作者
一個藝術家而活著這樣
那也萬萬就沒有想到
突然發生這樣的一個變故
然後就開始從事殯葬工作
然後管理一間公司
然後服務這些旅客
但憑良心講
我覺得那個時候更多是一種
就是環境形勢所逼
然後你問我說
我喜不喜歡這份工作
我那時候都沒有
時間去想這件事情
你就是去面對它
但是你說討厭嗎
不至於就是享受
那種服務 家人
然後得到肯定的那種成就感
可是你說真的愛這個工作嗎
好像也還好
然後我覺得是在幾年後
就是我覺得人生
剛好遇到一些波折
然後遇到滿大的挫敗
那我覺得在低谷的時候
有比較多的時間開始自我覺察
卻想就是說在短短的這一生
我到底要如何活出
我自己想要的樣子
那如果要做一份工作
是我自己所熱愛的
那殯葬行業它真的
會是我想要的工作嗎
那所以我覺得
那個時候我
大量的做一些探索
包含那時候也讀了一些書
包含像那個
有本書叫找到你的為什麼
就在講那個Golden
Circle
在講你的核心的動力
很多的這種摸索之後
就意外發現一個很有趣的
是以前沒想過
就是為什麼人類需要這樣一設
然後為什麼現在的
社會需要這些儀式
比如說現在很多社會形態
價值觀都在改變
傳統儀式還有保留的必要嗎
還是我們可以做一些改變呢
那改變的依據又是什麼呢
其實那時候就開始有很多
這樣的一個好奇
那最終我整理的一個概念就是
我的核心那個Why就是
我希望能夠創造一個讓人不
害怕死亡的世界
因為我覺得死亡就成
如我剛剛我入手說的
就是海德格爾有講過嘛
就是像死而生
就是很多時候我們
是以中為實在過生活
那你會活得很有力量
所以不畏懼死亡是
很重要的第一步
因為你不會懼他
你才有談他的可能性這樣
那具體要怎麼做呢
那就是有的好
第二權就是我們希望
用比較美麗的方式
比較優雅的方式
不要傳統刻板印象
也就是一想到殯葬一想到死亡
就覺得好可怕
然後再來就是我們有一種比較
輕鬆的方式來聊
徬彿在聊那種出國旅遊的計畫
這樣的一個方式來做
讓大家可以更接受這件事情
那最後的那個what
那我具體做什麼
所以從原本的冰葬的行業
就是我們在服務家人
陪伴這些儀式之外
可能比如說出書啦
做podcast啦
然後甚至做一些遊戲卡牌啊
然後辦一些活動
工作坊、論壇等等的
那拍電影之類的
就是我們都希望
透過不同的面向
然後陪著大家來一起探索死亡
這樣的一個命題
所以回到剛剛的問題說
我為什麼會做這份工作
我覺得是一可能
說是沒得選被迫選擇
那第二階段就是
我覺得我找到那個使命感
就是我覺得這個
工作實在太值得做了
很有意思
然後就懷抱的熱情
然後就做到現在
嗯
我我剛剛聽你在分享這個部分
你想得很清楚
那我我很好奇的是那個使命感
因為
面對死亡的這個議題
像你剛剛說的
我們不恐懼
我們能夠不恐懼
我們就能面對它
但這句話講起來
雖然好像很平鋪直述
但其實很困難
不容易
因為比如說像
因為我先生工作是醫生
然後我印象很深刻
那個時候在他還在念書
就是開始實習的時候
他在第一次送走病人的時候
即使是我看他平常就是一個
沒血沒淚的傢伙
我覺得那個時候
對他的心理衝擊
跟感受是非常非常強大
然後我我自己在
從事現在這個工作
在面對有時候工作
上需要面對他人
他的生活跟可能正在經驗
比如說經驗他的重要家人
或重要他人的離開
然後他必須要去面對
或是我自己在面對
我自己的重要他人的離開
我覺得那都不是
一件非常容易的事
因為特別到某個年紀的時候
你會開始感受到
尤其是如果是跟你同年紀的人
因為生病為什麼東西
他可能有一些就是生命的變化
也許真的就提早畢業了
那個對自己的衝擊是很大的
可是我們大部分的人
可能會在日常生活中
因為都有一些
Routine的事情要做
所以大家就把
這個東西放到旁邊
但你的工作是我就是必須要
一直去面對這個東西
到我能夠告訴自己
我不用恐懼這個事情
到我想幫助大家
不要恐懼這個事情
這中間其實有很多困難
這個問題問得很棒
你覺得這裡面
不愧是老師
沒有沒有沒有
就是你覺得
因為我覺得你的
這個經驗很不容易
所以你怎麼讓自己不怕去面對
你又怎麼讓大家不怕去面對
我先講就是怎麼樣讓大家不怕
就是說因為恐懼來自於未知
然後所以我覺得
透過大量的去聆聽或去探索
或是請聽別人曾經
發生過的一些故事
我覺得它都是一些養分
慢慢積累這件事情
因為我很相信這件事情
會讓我們不害怕死亡
是因為我自己就是這樣過來的
因為我在這20
多年的經驗當中
從小學然後開始接觸死亡
到現在這個歷程
其實我也走過三個階段
第一個階段在面對死亡的時候
我覺得是一種震撼
就像你剛剛說說到
就是第一次面對一個生命
從你手上離開
那對我來說就是一個
非常大的shock
震驚
我記得我那時候第一個
我自己親手服務的
案件是一個女孩子
她從那個樓頂上跳樓跳下去
當時我們抵達
現場的一個小時前
她還是一個活生生的人
可是當我抵達現場的時候
她已經就是奄奄一息
就是躺在地板上
然後等待我們去協助她
裝進Ｏ袋裡面這樣的一個工作
那在搬運的過程當中
你摸到她的時候她還是熱的
還是熱的
然後你很難想像
一個這樣年輕的女孩
然後就這樣子永遠
的離開這個世界
然後你感受到是
一個生命力的消失
然後那是我第一次直視死亡
這件事情在我面前
就說原來這是死亡
那是一種很大的一種震撼
然後直到在大一些
我也沒有曾經為他人的這種
就是離去造成自己
內在很長一段時間的
這種情緒的耗損
那個是一個經驗是
有一次我們接到一個電話
那有一個中年婦女
打來就說我的孩子過世了
然後你們能不能夠來幫忙
就處理後續
然後我們就說好那沒問題
那麻煩給我地址
那我們現在立刻派人過去現場
協助你做後面流程的安排
然後這個媽媽就突然就說
不要不要不要這麼快
你不需要那麼快
不用那麼快就是等一下
再給我一點時間就好
再一下下就好
然後那個時候的經驗
直覺告訴我這個有問題
所以中間幾經波折
反正最終我們就是報警了
因為也拿到地址報警了
然後就去現場
要去看狀況怎麼樣
因為他拒絕讓我們去處理後續
因為他甚至有點
到後來是很激烈的
他說你不要來
那那個轉折就是
你會覺得很困惑
為什麼會這樣
那個反應也不是很正常
你從他電話裡面的語氣
潤述的方式表達等等
你都覺得這個有問題
等到警察按電鈴
然後沒有回應破門
然後進去之後就發現
這個媽媽在昨晚
已經把他的小朋友
就是結束他小朋友的生命
然後也在警方破門抵達之前
然後輕生選擇離開這個世界
然後那一年我高中
對 就是那個時候
我會開始在想說
是不是我反應太慢
然後是不是我
處理的方式太笨拙
我有沒有更好的處理方式
然後可以去免除
這樣子的遺憾發生
所以我自責自己
很長一段的時間
我覺得這件事情跟我有關
那真的好痛苦
因為你忍不住會背負
一個生命的消失
兩個生命的消失
真的
所以這件事情對我來講
其實有很大的
內耗因壓力在我自己生命上面
經歷很長一段時間
那也是在後來真的
看了越來越多的旅客們
然後有不同的家庭樣貌
人生價值觀的樣貌
然後有很多很光明 很溫暖的
也有很多很黑暗 很不堪的
然後當你越看越多之後
你會理解到說
這就是一個重聲響
就是每個人的生命
都有他自己的功課
每個人的生命
都有他自己的選擇
而我也有我自己的選擇
而我的無能為力是
承認自己無能為力這件事情
是很重要的第一件事情
就是我不是神
我不是上帝
就是唯有我自己能力的極限
所以後來聽到有一個朋友
在跟我分享了一個概念
就是說每件事情到你面前
你必要拆解三件
就是我的事、他的事跟老天的事
對 就是我的事
是否建立完成了
那如果是
那接下來就是他跟老天的事
那我覺得這件事情就是
讓我在面對死亡的第二階段
開始慢慢去理解
一 就是我的無能為力
二 就是每個人都有他自己
生命當中的遺憾
那包含我自己我的生命經驗
也有很多我自己的創傷跟遺憾
那到了20年後的現在
那我覺得我到了第三階段
就是當我不但看得夠多
而且我也算是走了一段時間了
所以我也看著
這些遺憾是怎麼樣
經歷過時間而改變他的樣貌
比如說我父親走今年12年
在12年的前半段的五六年
對我來說都是遺憾
沒有什麼好懸念的
就是我生命當中的創傷跟遺憾
可是長到12年後的現在
我覺得這個遺憾慢慢變成
是我生命當中很重要的養分
他讓我更知道我要珍惜
要守護
然後要在意的信仰是什麼
然後也讓我在這些遺憾當中
更加珍惜懂得
我在乎我想要去努力
的那個方向是什麼
所以當然有時候會講
遺憾變成禮物就要
有點雞湯這樣子
但我真心相信
就是我覺得那些
經歷到了如今的現在
他已經變成我生命的禮物了
比如說我因為有很多
生命的經歷跟故事
我出了兩本書
然後拿了兩座金鐘獎
然後也做了一個
YouTube節目
那當然我覺得
獎項那個什麼倒是其次
那就是一個別人
對你的一個肯定
可是你就會發現說
走著走著走到現在
那這些也變成是我生命當中
一個不可或缺人生經歷
然後也讓我有力量
可以幫助我身邊的人
所以當初的那些遺憾
他還是遺憾
可是他好像沒有那麼傷心了
這些遺憾他還是遺憾
但是他好像沒有那麼不堪了
就是我沒有必要說什麼走出來
沒有因為我已經可以
跟他好好和平相處
就是接受這個遺憾
就是我生命的一部分
所以我覺得
這也是我覺得這本書的書名
那個曲的那個聲音
叫做《想你時，
我終於可以笑著流淚》
就是你不會不流淚的
你家人過世哪怕
10年 20年
有時候你想到的時候
心裡還沒還是酸酸的
可是也許有一天
你接納它是你生命
的一部分的時候
你可以笑著流淚
那個笑著裡面有很多的情感
包含了也許你理解了他人
你理解了自己
你長大了
或者是你終於懂得
怎麼去跟他和平相處
所以這個就是我自己
在看待死亡的過程
就回到你剛剛講
我怎麼經歷到這個
因為我剛剛在聽你講
我覺得好像在面對死亡的那個
最困難的部分
我剛剛聽到你講到
兩個很有智慧的部分
一個部分是我會接受
有些事情我真的是無能為力
我真的沒有辦法
然後我能確定
就是我把很多事情
我有做好
我該做好我有做好
然後我就去面對
後面的事情的部分
我覺得這是在面對
死亡很不容易的部分
因為我們在現在的日常生活
可以控制的東西太多了
越來越多事情可以控制
然後所以我們會甚至期待
我每件事情都可以控制的時候
在死亡面前
我們是沒有辦法控制的
然後第二個是
因為我們想要控制每一件事情
因為我們不想要後悔
不想要有遺憾
然後這就是你剛剛
說的第二個部分
就是我們
我們要接受
對 我們生命就是會有遺憾
它就是個創傷
我覺得這兩件事情講
起來也是很不容易
可是卻把
我們怎麼去面對
這個死亡的困難
又拆解得更清楚
為什麼我們沒辦法
為什麼我們覺得很恐怖
為什麼它很未知
我們就很害怕
未知的事情這麼多
我也不知道我會不會中樂頭
但是我不會那麼怕這件事
但我不知道死亡這件事情
它為什麼會讓我那麼多
那麼多害怕
是因為死亡本身在死亡面前
不管是發生在我們身上
或是旁邊的人的身上
甚至離我們很遠的人身上
我們都感覺到無能為力
我覺得那個無能為力
跟它一定會造成一些遺憾
然後只要我們的
鏡像神經元發展得還不錯
就是我們同理心還不錯
我們就很難不感覺到遺憾
我們很難不會感覺到
這個家庭的破碎的遺憾
這個發生在別人事情的遺憾
甚至發生在我們
自己身上的遺憾
我剛剛在聽你講
因為我之前有在我
自己節目分享過
就是我的奶奶過世
對我來說是一個很大的
shock
因為
因為我奶奶是心臟病過世的
所以是很突然的
然後那時候她還很年輕
那時候我才大學
所以對於這個遺憾本身
它到現在
就是我夢到她都還是會哭
然後就像你說的
我們終於可以笑著悲傷
我印象中很深刻的是
在幾年前我夢過
我每次夢到她都是哭
就是因為那時候正在討論
她要來參加我的畢業典禮
然後她就一直很開心
我念北一女
然後我北一女的畢業典禮
家人說要來參加
我說我來參加幹嘛
你們誰都不准來
我們沒有同學來參加
不准來
然後所以他非常期待大學
她可以來政大參加畢業典禮
然後我就想說在山上
大家為什麼要那麼累
然後但是他們就說
他們想來 我想說好
結果才聊到過沒有兩個禮拜
不到半個月我奶奶就走
而且非常突然
然後所以這件事情
一直是我一個很深的遺憾
就一直覺得說
我怎麼沒有花多一點時間陪他
我怎麼沒有留意他的身體
不夠健康
我怎麼沒有發現
我怎麼讓他一個人
孤零零的在路邊
然後就這樣走了
然後那個時候他在想什麼
然後我是不是少做什麼
我覺得那個人生會不停的
在那個遺憾中打轉
其實我自己是
就是做心理師
可是我覺得那個感覺
還是會覺得說
就是那一個覺得自己
就像你剛剛說的
那兩個生命的離開
我是不是做得不夠多
我是不是少做了什麼
然後我還能不能再做什麼
我覺得要成福在那個無力感
跟我一定會有遺憾
這件事情好難
你怎麼做到這件事
我覺得就是回到剛剛講
就是真的看得夠多
因為
就是一個洪水法的概念
對 就是
因為以前的世界只有自己
然後自己的家庭
然後你的生命經驗是有限的
所以你就認為
我好像彷彿只有這個選項
也就是一直不斷的出課題
給自己說
一定是我做得不夠
一定我怎麼樣這樣
就是你會有很多
折磨自己的方式
就是你放心好了
就是你都會找到機會的
所以
哪怕我自己工作這麼多年
那
甚至到前幾年COVID
那個時候
我有一個很重要的家人離開的
那書裡面大概有寫
那是我的養母
那
我內心還是有很多關過不去
那個過不去是
他走的時候
他那時候60歲
其實也很年輕
那他的居住地
他獨自一個人
獨居在一個離我公司
就是開車三分鐘
就可以到的地方
就是屬於那種就是
就在那邊啊
就在旁邊
要過去三分鐘就到了
這種距離
然後每次都跟自己講說
有空再去吧
有空再說吧
我很忙
我工作現在很重之類的
然後
但是就在COVID那一陣子
他突然有一天
就是我阿姨打電話過來給我
就說媽媽走了
怎麼怎麼可能
那時候悲傷五階段就來了
先否認了
就是
怎麼可能甚至有憤怒的情緒說
天啊
然後哪有發生這樣的事情
你看很諷刺
哪怕自己是做殯葬業的
其實也都
會有這些情緒
然後甚至到了現場
然後看著我的媽媽
那
因為她是第三天才被發現
所以她手腳四肢已經發黑
然後眼睛睜的大大的
然後看著天花板
然後嘴巴張得大大的
然後我就回想起就是
上一次在跟她聊的時候
她還在跟我講說
最近那個胸有點悶啊
心臟不舒服
要去看醫生啊什麼的
然後我們還是跟她講說
啊那你就要多保重身體啊
就講這種很冠冕堂皇
的廢話
就在碰面的時候她已經離開
那那個時候其實也是
很沒有辦法原諒自己
就會覺得說天啊
我
我怎麼會讓這件事情發生
然後
說好的吃飯
說好的將去
就是一隔又是隔的大半年
然後你真的有這麼忙嗎
你真的有這麼就是
連那麼一點時間都沒有嗎
就回到剛剛那個就是
我能不能再多做些什麼
就是我 你放心好
就是即使哪怕我做那麼多
我看那麼多
你第一時間的情緒
你還是會充滿各種責怪
就覺得我到底
我到底怎麼了
你怎麼可以讓這件事情發生
我那時候甚至害怕恐懼到
我連
就是去幫我媽媽
整理她的儀容
然後收進Ｏ袋入殮我都不敢
我那時候就是有一種恐懼
就是我不知道該如何去
面對這樣子一個情緒這樣
後來還是同時受不了
就說老闆 沒關係我來吧
就是做這件事情
我到現在都很自責
所以
這種東西準備再多都沒有用
哪怕我們這種殯葬行業的人
哪怕自己的事情
其實我們都一樣
我們還是凡人
這些情緒我們一樣都有
那我只能說就是
剛剛聊到說
我們在看待遺憾這件事情
我們怎麼樣看起來
好像相對比較從容
就回到剛剛講就是
因為我們看夠多
所以我們其實
很快要放下那些執著
因為知道我們也只能這樣
因為它不可能再重來
它也沒有機會再重來
讓我們能夠想的事情是
如果媽媽她還在
她就在我面前
然後她看著我現在的樣子
她會跟我說什麼
然後她會期待我用生涯的方式
去過我接下來的生活
那如果我們要繼續往前走
我還能這麼做
那所以我覺得在那個過程當中
也給自己很多的心思
那接納自己的無能為力
所以這件事情在我生命當中
也留下一些種子
好比說在
COVID之後的這些年
我會刻意讓自己的一年當中
會留下幾天空白的時間
然後那個空白的時間就是
我稱之為叫封鎖時間
也就是我會特別
把它lock起來
如果這一年我有一些
就是嘴巴講說
我好久沒看到它了
然後或是有時候會這樣
在路上你會遇到一個
很久不見的好老朋友
然後你們都會說
欸 好久不見
真的是
不好意思
我現在趕下一個行程
找個機會我們真的好好
好好再聚一聚吃個飯
欸 我們再一個
Line吧這樣子
然後說下次見面一下
那就沒見面了
就再也沒聚這樣
那有些是場面話
那就算了
你知道那是場面話就OK了
那就無所謂
可是如果倘若那個人是
你真的很想
真的好好在促膝長談
那封鎖時間就很重要
那就很好用
那就是一個
專門拿來讓你
可以去跟你想見的人碰面
就這樣
所以我覺得那也是我的
媽媽我的養母在
這件事情在我生命當中
留下的這個遺憾
而帶給我的
我也是稱之為叫禮物
我願意用禮物來看它
就是遺憾還是遺憾
但是
我沒有辦法再去改變
這個遺憾的定義了
因為它就是遺憾
我沒有要沒話它
只是我不想讓它白白發生
所以我讓這件事情
在我的生命當中
我試著
在這個遺憾當中
找到一點
看起來像是禮物的可能
所以這件事情它就
很大程度改變我生活的樣態
我面對相處朋友這些的樣態
所以
我不是神
我是凡人
所以很多人有的情緒我也都有
只是我們
能夠轉念的
能夠重新覺察自己狀態的
時間可能比較快一點
如隨
但不代表我沒有感覺
不代表我沒有情緒
不代表我沒有遺憾
只是我更懂得怎麼樣跟
這一個發生和平相處
我很同意你講的那個遺憾
它永遠都是遺憾
那那個事情發生了
其實就是發生了
那是沒有辦法改變
我們永遠都覺得準備不夠
我自己在
面對就是我
家人過世這件事情
特別是我奶奶的那個部分
我覺得有比較多的部分都是
就是一開始是這些
剛剛所有的那些情緒
我印象很深刻
後來我有稍微
覺得好一點的地方
是有一次
那時候我們還在
就是要送奶奶的過程
就是那個頭七那幾天
然後呢
我們不知道是誰先開始了
就開始聊奶奶
跟奶奶的一些美好回應
然後我們就開始聊
原本我們前面大家都是一直哭
因為太突然
一開始大家都嚇到
後來大家都是一直哭
然後到開始的聊
我們跟他的美好回應
有時候我們開始會笑
然後我們也不會覺得
那個笑很突兀
我那時候就覺得說
原來是因為有這些
很美好的東西
所以我們才會覺得
那個遺憾這麼無法忍受
因為我們知道那個美好
可能沒有辦法再回來
沒錯
可是那個美好它
它是存在的
它沒有辦法再回來
我們可能沒有辦法再驚豔
可是我們可以重溫
在我們的記憶裡面
那個東西很難去說
說明
但是每一次我們在覺得
很遺憾跟很痛的時候
其實就是因為
我們之前的那個美好
很棒
剛剛我剛好在跟
前面的訪談者在聊
我就是因為前陣子我去芬蘭
然後我就說芬蘭
讓我最受不了的
就是沒什麼陽光
然後他就問我說
我是一個很喜歡熱的人
我就說其實也還好
我沒有那麼喜歡熱
我大概就喜歡就是20幾度
最多這樣子
然後我想說我沒有很喜歡
可是我很喜歡陽光
我一直不知道為什麼
我這麼喜歡陽光
然後我本來是解釋成
我以前住在基隆
就是小時候曾經有一段時間
住在基隆一天下雨
所以我很討厭下雨
那我後來發現
不我真的很喜歡陽光
剛剛在跟你聊的時候
我才想起來
因為以前小時候我住台南
就是在很小
我出生地在台南
然後每一次回台南的時候
跟奶奶相處的時候
常常我印象最深刻都是午後
然後太陽是從窗戶照進來
然後整個家裡
那時候透天嘛
都很多窗戶
所以採光都非常好
我覺得對我來說
那是一個非常溫暖的回憶
然後每次想到奶奶
都是這樣的回憶
所以對我來說
陽光就是一個讓我
每次看了都會很有感受
我覺得有的時候
好像跟這個人的一些美好
他會就是用這種方式
就是滲進你的骨髓裡
然後你不知道為什麼
然後在那些遺憾當中
這些美好也是同時存在的
因為很愛
所以才會那麼遺憾
沒錯
對 所以我覺得
那個遺憾本身是
我
我跟你的想法的確比較不一樣
我比較不會把它當成是禮物
但是我會覺得
它就是一個一體兩面
因為那個美好存在
如果是我們的仇人離開
我的遺憾可能就不會很像
但是如果是我很重要的人
有給我很美好回憶的人
我們可能就會覺得
哎呀 我們怎麼沒有
再讓這些美好回憶多一點
但是也許真的這個世界
來說
那個美好可能永遠不夠
所以我覺得我好能理解
你說的那個感覺
那如果我們回到這本書
因為你最近剛好出了一本書
叫做《想你時，終於可以笑著流淚》
這個說明也蠻打動我的
雖然我常常會覺得
對 就是我很希望
就像我說我夢到我奶奶
我希望我可以笑著流淚
但是每次都還是會流淚
就是還是覺得很難過
然後
但是這一本書裡面
我可以感覺到很多
你自己自身的一些體驗
沒錯
我想說
你可以不會幫我們介紹一下
就是你從第一本書到第二本書
你的那個心路歷程
跟你想帶給大家的東西
可以
當初第一本書書名叫做
《最後三通電話你會打給誰》
那其實這是一個假命題
因為真實的人生是
你想完了你三個對象
你要打電話給他
然後接著你還想完了
你要跟他說什麼
然後接著我會很殘酷的告訴你
就是其實你沒有這三通電話
因為我們沒有辦法預知未來
也因此就是我永遠沒有辦法
理解哪一次是最後一次
哪一句話會是最後一句
所以我想透過
我看到了很多的這種
生理死別的遺憾
然後聽別人的
故事長自己的智慧
就是發現
我們要好好地活在當下這樣
那甚至書裡面也
教大家如何準備
然後自己在面對死亡課題上
需要安排的功課等等的這些
那所以因為初書的關係
有機會去很多地方演講
然後分享
那很多人就說
謝謝這個書
讓他有開始面對死亡的勇氣
然後讓他知道從
哪裡開始等等的
但也開始有一種聲音會跑出來
就說
我好後悔看你的書
然後或者好後悔上你的課
然後你就很驚訝說為什麼這樣
後來就發現
在他們的世界當中
他認為無知是一種幸福
就原本沒有聽你講還沒事
可是聽完之後就發現
天啊我有太多的遺憾
無處安方
然後你跟我講說要珍惜
但是我無從珍惜
因為我愛的人都已經不在了
然後那些遺憾都已經造成了
我還能怎麼辦
然後所以我那時候就開始回顧
我自己的經驗
就覺得說
我似乎好像
也沒有那麼理所當然
就是我爸爸過世之後
沒有錯
我喪禮大概兩三個禮拜就
看
Joyimachi就結束了
可是我每次上電視節目都在哭
每次只要一檔到說
爸爸開始哭這樣子
然後聊到一些情境又開始促進
傷心眼淚又開始流
前面幾年都還OK
就是大家都會覺得說
很不捨
年紀輕輕就爸爸就
這樣突然不見了
那應該很多創傷等等
然後哭到幾年過去了
有時候YouTube下面
那個網友都很兇
就哭整天（台）
哭完沒（台）
然後甚至有些就是是善意的
大家就會說
你要不要去看醫生
我覺得你應該有點狀況
我看的時候也很有感觸
就是我也問我自己說
我說對
我也不想再流淚了
可是我做不到
然後就算人家講說
你也是做殯葬的
你應該看很多
你應該看很開
我說沒有
發生在別人身上叫正常
發生在自己身上叫無常
就是我第一次當商家
我那經歷創傷這件事情
對我來說我人生第一次
那是我多麼重要的家人
而且這種經驗是無可比擬的
因為這是我跟我父親
非常獨特的這種情感的
這種依戀的關係
所以我也想知道我到底怎麼了
我能夠對這個悲傷
我能夠做些什麼
所以當然中間有
很多的一些波折
但是我覺得算是開啟了我
對於這個自我覺長
然後還有去梳理自己狀況
我覺得一個很重要的覺醒
我舉個例子
比如說書裡面
其中有個章節就是奶奶的壽衣
她講的一個概念是
背後的情境是
我當初在醫院我是
在病塌下答應我父親
要傳承他的公司
所以我許下了一個承諾
我告訴她說
不管這些公司怎麼樣
我會經歷的延續下去
但不意外的
就是年輕不懂事
就是幾年過去
就是這間公司就
跟我沒有什麼關係了
就是整間公司
就我父親一手
打造的心血就沒了
然後我那個時候
也背負了一大筆的負債
那負債是小
然後去面對這些挑戰也都是小
但是我覺得最
沒有辦法承受的是
我違背了我當初對我
父親的承諾跟諾言
那我覺得就是一種
無顏見江東父老
這樣的一個創傷
然後我說天啊我當初是如此的
自我感覺良好
覺得我可以把
這件事情做得很好
但我卻是一位院位
我辜負了我父親對我的期待
我無法原諒我自己
而這個奶奶她出現了
她是我生命當中的一盞明燈
就是她的出現
教會我如何去面對這件事情
那這故事是這樣就是
那天深夜奶奶打電話過來
然後她就說她的先生過世了
那希望我去現場幫忙說好
到了現場中看到一個老夫妻
生活在一個非常狹小的空間
然後七八十歲的
一堆老夫妻沒有小孩
走進房間看著老先生
全身就是非常的瘦弱
那像皮包骨一樣
躺在一個非常
專業的那種醫療床
大家可以感受得到
就是這個老奶奶
已經照顧先生很長一段時間了
然後接下來這老奶奶她非常
熟練的告訴我說
哎待會是不是ABCDE
12345那種步驟
告訴我說要做什麼或做什麼
然後我現場說天啊你怎麼
那麼樣的流暢
這樣子我想說
應該是同行來踢館的這樣
然後我說對對沒錯就是
那你要可以準備
一套先生的衣服給我
那待會我幫你換衣穿這樣說好
然後她說可是我
現在行動不太方便
你能不能幫我拿
我說好
她把我帶到一個儲藏
室裡面堆滿的雜物
積滿的灰塵
然後她指著那個就是衣櫥最
上方角落的一個盒子
她說你幫我拿這樣說好
然後當我在翻閱我說
奶奶是這一盒嗎
然後奶奶說
不是不是那盒是我的
旁邊那盒才是我先生的
然後我突然一下子腦子就炸了
我就說啊天啊就是這對夫妻
她不但已經準備好身後事
是彼此都準備好一份
然後我就問他們說你們怎麼了
怎麼樣的開明且豁達
然後對一個你知道七八歲的
老奶奶有點難想像
然後他們就告訴
我就奶奶就告訴我說
他們在年輕的時候
就曾經想過有小孩
但事與願違
那後來這對夫妻在
很多年前就約定好
就是他們有意識到這兩夫妻
一定會有一個人先走
所以他們的承諾就是
留下來的那一個人
要打起精神
要很有勇氣
好好的送另外一個人最後一程
那那是他們夫妻
之間的一種承諾
所以我那時候
當下有很大的感動
是在於說我突然
理解到一個事情就是
沒有所謂的白頭到老這件事情
就是夫妻就跟講電話一樣
就是不管你講得多開心
總有一個人要先把
電話掛掉這樣子
那我也想說對啊
其實你看喪禮就是這樣嘛
就是一定會不管是
老先生或老太太
一定會有一個人
照片放在正中央
然後一定會有一個人會坐在
第一排第一個
你很少
我這20幾年我很少遇到
你知道夫妻一起走的
除非這是比如說交通意外等等
但很少
然後你看哦
所以一對老夫妻
哪怕先生不外遇
然後太太就是很愛他的先生
相濡以沫走過大半輩子
但是還是有要說再見的那一天
那如果連情愛關係
這麼樣深的羈絆
都會走到這樣的結局
那一間公司又算得了什麼呢
就是你那個以為就是
天大不了的一間公司
又算得了什麼
他只要在商業登記書
他登記他成為
有限公司的那一天開始
他就注定他有一天一定會結束
只是什麼時候而已
所以我覺得我那個時候
他讓我放下了一個很大的執著
就是我以前會覺得
像剛剛講的很多遺憾
其實背後有一個
東西就是我很愛他
再加上我很在乎
但是再更強烈一點
就變成一種執念
就是我覺得我好希望我一輩子
可以擁抱著他
我可以一輩子擁有著他
可是這所有的故事
都在告訴我一件事情
就是你這輩子你
擁有不了任何東西
那也是一種控制感的執念
要臣服在無力感
前面其實很不容易
很不容易
所以你就看著這些故事的發生
你就覺得
你就算你想執著你也無力執著
因為這些故事的發生
就一而再再而三的告訴你
就是你擁有不了任何東西
你只有辦法經歷他
然後再跟他
就東方在講姻緣嘛
你只能說當你跟他在有緣
相遇的時候
你有沒有珍惜那個關係
如此而已
至於誰要先下車怎麼下車
那都不是你可以決定的
真的
我覺得在聽你剛剛
講這些東西的時候
包含你剛剛說在
YouTube
提到你爸爸的時候
你還會哭
然後下面的朋友留言
然後很狠狠的
我都感受到一件很明顯的事情
就是談死亡
這件事情之所以不容易
是因為面對負面情緒
跟面對無力感這件事情
在我們的文化當中
本身就是一件很困難的事情
非常非常困難
我們非常希望
可以消除負面情緒
我遇過
就算我從事這一行
也有很多人會告訴我說
我希望可以不要焦慮
我希望不要害怕
我希望我在面對事情的時候
我可以情緒很穩定
我希望我不要難過
我希望我不要悲傷
可是這些情緒本身
它其實是一個
它真的就是一個提醒
它就像我們遇到火
我們燙到就會痛
那個東西不能沒有
那是我們身為一個人
活在這個世界上
感覺這個世界非常重要的關鍵
可是因為那些感受太痛苦了
我們不知道怎麼面對
我們不知道它
什麼時候會停下來
那個無力感
就會讓我們更不喜歡
這些負面情緒
所以我覺得那些
在留言說
哭這麼久
可以停了吧
的人們
某方面來說
也是在看到你這樣子的情緒的
無能為力
跟感受到
好像這件事情就是沒完沒了
不知道什麼時候會停
的那個感覺
會帶給我們一個失控感
這些感覺會讓我們很想要制止
這個傷心的人
所以其實我常常會在
很多時候遇到有些人會跟我說
我現在譬如說假設是
譬如說孩子走了
父母走了
這種很重要的關鍵的心情
然後我現在聊到的時候會哭
然後我旁邊的人或是失戀
我旁邊的人就會說
你夠了吧
這麼久了
可以了吧
然後
他是說
他就會覺得他自己做錯事了
然後以前年輕的時候
我都會想說
不是還你哭你的
又沒有拜託你一起哭
你是在那邊有意見什麼
就我以前都會很沒有同理心
要這樣講
但是其實我這樣講也是沒錯
但是話說回來
如果我們回到覺察
我自己本身在看到
對方這個狀況的時候
我為什麼會想要制止他
為什麼想要勸他
為什麼希望他去調整
很大是因為我要
跟你一起去體會
這個無力感本身
其實很可怕的
那個可怕是
我要跟你一起去
感受這個負面情緒
這個無力感
這個失控感
這個事情沒有辦法變化
他就是這樣
因為這個遺憾就是長這樣
那其實是一件很可怕的事情
而且我們在東方文化
就成如像你剛剛所講的
就是我們的社會
不那麼喜歡負面情緒
所以哪怕像我們在喪禮的場合
最常最常聽到的就是那種親友
來到現場
看到那個太太哭的很傷心
就開始拍她肩膀
接著就講
節哀
我就心想
節你個頭
當然就不能這樣講啦
就是
就像有時候安慰的時候
我就覺得
有時候那個節哀
真的會造成當時更大的壓力
我小時候都覺得
我是一個很不會安慰人類的
所以我後來去當心理師的時候
我也是很擔心這一點
就是我常常會在
別人出現負面情緒的時候
我不知道要說什麼
所謂不知道要說什麼
就是因為我覺得那一個損失
或是那個傷心
或是那個創傷
實在太巨大了
我覺得我沒有辦法說任何事情
讓這件事情可以回到原點
不可能的
所以我常常都待在那邊
然後心裡想說完蛋了
現在我到底該做什麼
可是
如果我們希望
我們可以好一點
這件事情
有時候在面對很重要的事情的
創傷或是傷心的事情
或是遺憾
有的時候要好一點
還真不容易
不容易 不容易
但我們如果能夠
接受這件事情
對我們的重要性
能夠看到這一點
或許我們就更能知道
這個遺憾本身對我們的意義
我這也具體的經驗是
我覺得在我經歷面對
悲傷也好 遺憾也好這個過程
我覺得最療癒的是
在我父親走之後
有很多身邊的一些朋友
那他們是一些節目的企劃
Re通告的這些
他們就說
你要不要來上上節目這樣
因為那時候當然一方面
知道說我要接家業
那沒有人認識小冬瓜
所以他們的初衷其實很單純
就是希望說
幫忙曝光
他其實也沒有多想太多
可是他們在跟我
互動的過程當中
其實他們不會
刻意去表現出一種
就是你就的那種表情
就是好好彷彿
就是朋友日常這樣
然後接著他們會問很多
就是很中性的問題
然後開始去探索
比如說他會問說
你跟你爸爸
就是為什麼會弄到離家出走
就是很多好奇
然後接著會說
那你幾歲開始有
這樣的一個情緒
然後我覺得
很多問題
我沒有想過
然後這些問題的產生
他逼著我
當然某種程度上有點壓力
我必須得層次的這樣
可是我覺得當我後來試過
今天回過來看
其實我後來發現
這些問題其實很重要
因為他幫助我在那個
很混亂的那些情緒的過程當中
我後來有讀到一個概念
好像叫做情緒顆粒度
就是原本我爸爸過世的時候
我只有一個情緒叫做
我好悲傷
我好難過
可是悲傷跟難過
他大到很抽象
就是我不太瞭解
我現在悲傷跟難過
最重要的動力來自於何方
就是我那個最大的悲傷是什麼
然後所以在跟這些
企劃在聊的過程當中
他們開始有點像是
在抽絲剝繭的
然後去做清創手術
然後去梳理我跟我
爸爸的那些情緒
然後包含我們發展
過程的那些脈絡跟關係
那包含比如說
你為什麼後來沒有做殯葬
你為什麼想要做藝術
你不喜歡殯葬嗎
你不喜歡你爸爸什麼之類的
然後就開始慢慢瞭解到說
原來我的悲傷也有好多情緒
比如說我的情緒也有包含
我好失落
因為我可能未來要接家業
我必須要放棄我的夢想
然後這個悲傷還包含了
比如說我好憤怒
就是你怎麼可以
在我還沒有來得及證明
我自己的時候
你就給我這樣走了
然後我好
我覺得這是好焦慮
就是我不知道你走了之後
你會留下多少問題給我
然後我得要去
怎麼樣去面對這些事情
然後我的無力感
等等的
然後系數發現有十幾種
完全不同的這種面向
然後就讓我對於在面對
我父親過世的
就是那個當下情感的創傷
我覺得變得很立體
那所以那個時候
在我後續再重新
從谷底要慢慢往上爬的時候
我比較有方向
就是我開始要安頓好
比如說我未來接家業
然後我可能要
放棄夢想這件事情
我要如何安放這個情緒
又或者是我能夠為這件事情
再多做些什麼
諸如此類的
那另外一個方面就是
很多時候我覺得我身邊的朋友
其實他們沒有表達出那種
就是我要憐憫你的那種狀態
而是說走啊我們出去玩啊
然後說我們去做我們之前
常做這些事情
我覺得那種安心感會讓我有種
就是他們
有時候不是言語
不是那個用字譴詞
而是那個狀態
就是旁邊會有一種就是
哎呀你別怕啦
你不是那個異歲的
對就你別怕
因為有我們在啊
你別怕你並不孤單
你別怕就是反正有什麼需要
我們反正我們都在這
對但是你不需要
我們不會打擾你
但是如果你有需要
我隨時都在這
然後他們就是表達這樣
然後每個人表達方式不一樣
有些人是完全不講話的
他只是默默出現在你旁邊
然後有些人他可能會用
他的一些行為去表達
但是你會感受到
他對你那種很真誠的那份關心
那我覺得那種就蠻支持我的
我覺得對我幫助很大
我剛剛聽你講那個
前面的那個部分
我特別有感覺
因為你說的沒有錯
就是一個情緒本身
他有辦法慢慢的
能夠熟練跟穩定下來
其實我們求的只有一個東西
就是我看得清楚
我才有知道怎麼安放他
真的
對但是當我們沒有
機會看清楚的時候
他常常都是一大團
一大團的時候
我們的我們就會一直覺得
這個還沒有還沒有結束
所以那個有辦法把他看清楚
然後能夠安放他
不代表我們不再有這些情緒
而是我知道我自己怎麼了
我知道我自己的事件怎麼了
所以我覺得
這應該也是你這本書
最想要帶給我們的感覺
因為你在爬書
你自己的這個過程中
怎麼樣去做到這樣子的事情
沒錯
我覺得這是一件非常棒的事情
對真的很謝謝小冬瓜
然後這一本書
《想你時，終於可以笑著流淚》
我在看的時候
其實我的感動度非常高
然後我覺得小冬瓜你也很會講
大家聽了如果覺得
剛剛整個那個故事的過程
你覺得非常非常感動
相信我當你買了這本書之後
你的感動度絕對會更高
而他會幫助我們去重新思考
很多我們的生命
還有不只是死亡
而是我們的生命
我們到底還想做什麼
還能做什麼
還要做什麼
好的今天真的很謝謝小冬瓜
然後也謝謝大家
那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉
掰掰